[Music]
2016 took an unexpected turn for Mariah
Carey when she split from her
billionaire fiance but you know what you
will not catch this diva singing the
break-up blues no instead she's rockin
in the holidays in Paradise and getting
us caught up on her life today we get to
see in the first episode you and your
gorgeous wedding dress just a little to
my right there just a little tiara what
goes through your mind when you see
those things how emotional is that for
you you know I could sit here and be in
this whole like emotional moment about
it but I'd rather just say well no safe
space you can say whatever you want look
all those moments are bittersweet but
you just have to focus on whatever
you're focusing on and keep it moving
have you had to read it to show it all
because obviously your life has changed
significantly since even we were filming
together things are you know they change
from day to day and I'm scarred forever
we got an advance peek at Mariah's world
before its premiere and aside from a
quick shot at a tease there is
absolutely zero sign of her ex
billionaire James Packer are you going
to keep the ring because I would okay
well then you just answered your
question for yourself on something our
female fans really love is hash tag and
convenience fee why do you think I'm in
deserve and inconvenience fee honey we
deserve so much more than that
amen we deserve everything no you don't
you dare
despite the split there is no shortage
of men in Mariah's life her accent it
Canon is supporting her through this
time and so is her backup dancer Bryan
Tanaka Bryan of course he's a hottie
love that bad lots of speculation as to
if you guys are dating or not can we
clear it out what is going on there cuz
he is fine
you have to just wait and watch the show
oh it's a potential romantic intrigue
Ryan Joey you're just me just being
dramatic biggest inspiration my baby's
neck is on the show as we saw how do you
guys work that out it's more like you
know he was coming to see the kids
anyway so I was like do you mind you
know being showing he was cool about it
so um it's just about being really nice
with the other parent and not making it
like a competition or anything like that
what are your plans for the holidays
well the usual plan we see Santa Claus
he comes every Christmas Eve and they
reindeer are there as well you have a
snowy Christmas and Aspen and it's just
my favorite it's my favorite time of
year always
you